Shane Stanley, Filmmaker/Author/Instructor: When
you find somebody's story that you want to tell,
if you're a producer I think the most
important thing that you need to do is…
Film Courage: Is it a producer's job to gather IP?
Shane: Well I would think so I mean
Neal Moritz who is the master behind fast and the
furious you think about how that that incredible
franchise was birthed off of an article in the
back of the metro and the la times I think it
was a metro section or valley section about
subculture of street racing and those cars
that's what a great producer does is they comb
articles a lot of lazy ones like to watch 2020
or dateline those things usually don't get made
into movies if they do they they only go so far
I find that some of the great producers that I've
been fortunate enough to know are the ones that
would give me the time of day to at least talk to
it's these these these guys are on the hunt they
are constantly looking for a needle in a haystack
whether it's Neal Moritz or David Heyman or
David Zillon I mean they're just constantly
looking looking and looking for that thing that
just knocks them over and I think good producers
don't wait for it to come to them I think it's
a producer's job to we talked about the music
industry earlier what made what made a great
record executive and it was the ones that
went to the nightclubs the Roxy The Whiskey
and Gazzarri's [nightclubs on the Sunset
Strip in West Hollywood, California], at
two o'clock on a Monday night and watch that
headlining band on a Monday or Tuesday that's
that's where bands like Van Halen were found and
I know I know their history but i'm just saying
that they were signed off of a really crappy
attended night on the strip on a weeknight and I
think producers need to be more proactive I think
we we have gotten to the point where it's we are
so used to everything being at our fingertips we
can research everything we instant gratification
and I think the days I mean there were I remember
when when I knew Neal Moritz years ago long before
we did gridiron gang together I never saw Neal
without scripts I mean every time you saw Neal
he had scripts he was always reading that guy
was just constantly he was a sponge for content
and it paid off look at the career he's had I mean
the guy's doing everything and it's about finding
those those books that nobody has the rights to
that you that you see wow this can this this ip
can change the world and i'd be careful if if
it's successful it's probably owned but I think
there are some gems out there that are waiting
to be found that it's always nice when a producer
especially somebody younger newer or somebody who
may be more green or not have the deep pockets
that some of these these folks have to be able to
find something and create it and and get it made
but I think it's it's a producer's job that's
if you're going to produce there's two kinds of
producers there's they're the ones that find the
ip raise the money get the distribution and the
stars attached and then there's the producers
that are more the line producers that are on
the film that are hiring the crew and getting the
locations and getting all the vendors and gear and
everything done but when you talk about a producer
who is going to do the suit side of the job
if you will I think it's just so important
to just be a sponge be open to anything
and everything you just never know where
you're going to find that that that thing
and how would one know if the rights are owned
whether it's life story rights or there's
actually a script or yeah in acquiring property is
several different ways you can do it I mean if one
of the one of the biggest passion pieces I have
that I swear i'm going to get made before I die
is the Kelly Sutton story I mean here's a
woman who held the speed record at Daytona
who's living with multiple sclerosis I mean she
was supposed to die when she was eight years old
she's cheated death seven times I think she's been
a widow three times over her story is unbelievable
I was shooting a documentary in Wyoming in
Montana when the whole world was on fire up
there back in like a 102 and I was sitting in a
holiday inn and we were we were basically being
kept in a hotel because of the fire danger
and I had nothing to do the TV’s were out
the electricity was out and I went to the lobby
of the hotel and I found this sports illustrated
and there was a tiny little sub article you could
read through the magazines and they've sometimes
got a little sub something on the side and it said
she'll she'll stop at nothing that was the name
of the article and it was about Kelly Sutton and
it was three paragraphs from a paragraph long it
was the most incredible piece i'd ever read I got
home I reached out to the family to nascar I found
her the internet wasn't as amazing back then was
able to find her talk to her parents got in touch
with Kelly flew out to a race watched her race
a nascar event and such a wonderful human being
and one of the one of the most delightful
business relationships I've had I feel like
we've failed we haven't gotten the film made
yet we came very close a couple times had a
green light at a network that an agent was good
enough to ruin agents are good at that but that
when you find somebody's story that you want
to tell if you're a producer I think the most
important thing that you you need to do is is is
be humble a lot of people in our industry go to
people with hype and pomp and circumstance with
all the promises and well look when somebody's
story is breaking news like the little girl
that fell into well 30 years ago every studio
in Hollywood's going to try to get that so step
aside you're not getting those rights chances are
but if you find something that you
like as an article in the back of a
three-year-old sports illustrated or you see
a piece on tv or you caught a news segment
I always say reach out as humble as possible
and just say look I fell in love with your
story I want to tell your story and I want to see
it's told in a way that you can be proud of that
will represent you and your family and just go in
with with a servant's heart I've been fortunate to
to own a lot of intellectual properties of
life rights whether it was the Rick and Dicky
Hoyt [Team Hoyt] story or the great iron gang
that's one that we had it's just it's about
being kind it's about being gentle it's not about
selling the hype a lot of people go into those
things not realizing that the people that they're
approaching are not Hollywood people so they're
very off put by our energy often whether we call
it passion or pomp and circumstance or just a
bunch of whatever. I don't know but we tend to go
in on ten a lot of these people have often just
gone through a pretty dramatic situation in their
life or a pretty extraordinary situation they're
being courted by all sorts of people or getting
all sorts of press that they're not used to and I
think it's important to remember that these people
are not of our world in business there are ways to
try to penetrate their their
their world and not be intrusive
great way to get ip though is to scour
articles oh articles datelines 2020s
you get to a point that where a lot of executives
will start hearing things and they'll say it
sounds like a dateline it sounds like a 20 20
story things are probably better served there
but there are some remarkable stories that
come out of them there really are I mean I
fell in love with it the Bruce Murakami story
I don't think everybody remembers that where
poor gentleman was his his wife and two children
got into a minivan and went to the store and they
were they were t-boned by a street racer killed
the wife and two kids and the kid was going to go
to prison and bruce stepped in and asked for mercy
from the court it was the ultimate story of of
compassion and trying to change a life instead of
sending a 16 year old kid to prison for 10 years
i'm going to take this kid under my wing i'm going
to and I saw it on dateline or 2020 like 20 years
ago bruce flew out met with him and and I really
liked bruce a lot but he was also being courted
by everybody else film ended up getting made I
think with Dean Cain and lifetime or something
but it was it was one of those things
you knew it was going to get made
is interesting but yeah it's about
you're basically pitching you
as a filmmaker we talk about writers going into
the roman pitching and you may not be a writer
if you're a producer but you have to meet the
family or the survivors people that have gone
through some extraordinary circumstances and try
to pitch them on feeling comfortable with you
I mean you're selling them on you and your
game plan and your tone and temperament
when did you realize you had to transition away
from screenwriting I was horrible at it I mean
it wasn't I just I worked as a screenwriter for
a number of years I was very fortunate I was more
passionate about being on set and working with
people i'm a people person at the end of the
day it's one of my many faults and when you're
a writer you're you're isolated you're locked up
and you're that way too as an editor which I still
get stuck doing but it's it's more interaction
but I just I just got to the point
I as I got older and realized where
my passions were and my energies were
and my strengths and weaknesses were
writing just I started working with people I
work a lot with CJ Wally I just when I read
his work it made me want to make movies again
I was I was done I was ready to phone be done
do the book go teach I had a teaching
opportunity at a university to come in and
I read a script that cj wrote and I said this guy
makes me want to keep making movies and I realized
that this this guy can tell the stories that the
kind of stories I want to tell and we collaborated
really well together and it's exciting when
you read somebody's work that inspires you
to keep going because I was I was tired I had been
beating a bag a long time and kind of thought I've
i've been very fortunate I've been very blessed
I made my mark good bad or different I made a
mark may have been a stain in some people's eyes
but I made one and I wanted to teach and inspire
and encourage the next generation and and I just I
just felt that the amount of time it took to write
and it wasn't allowing me to make a film a year
or two films a year the way I wanted to and it's
great to work with somebody who understands and
gets me knows how to write for schedule and budget
we want to tell the same stories
I don't need to do that anymore
what's it like having written and developed your
own work now hiring writers or partnering with
other writers to tell those stories well it's it's
nice to be able to focus on on certain things and
not spread out too thin write produce direct edit
get the financing all that stuff it's it really is
it's a taxing business I mean this business will
eat you up even if you have one job and spending
the years writing and developing something and
trying to get it financed and get it produced
it takes a lot of time and and I kind of go
back to having the ability to work with somebody
who we we both want to tell the
same stories we both want to make
fun action comedy action thriller female driven
let the guys sit in in the passenger seat let the
girls drive make these fun films and we we both
love the same kind of movies we're both inspired
by the same kind of movies going back to like the
old Hal Needham films dirt movies and fast cars
race against time cannonball run smoking a bandit
and it's just it's easy it's it's almost like we
don't it's like hey we're going to line up to
do another one what do you think about this
interesting okay what if we did that it's a
very simple process that the long part of it
is cj in our situation CJ will just go through the
whole breakdown and develop development notes and
basically block it out and then once that's
done the scripts come very fast it's a very
fast process like we did double threat that was
created in mid-September we were shooting that by
October 15th I mean we had a script in six days we
all knew the story we wanted to tell it was just
about going out and rolling a dice during covet
and doing it and as I said earlier it was the most
fun I've ever had making a movie and I hope I hope
that translates on the screen we had a lot of fun.
What do you like about this video?